[Music]
Carrie Underwood rocked cma stage last
night as a co-host and a performer and
many were hoping that she would take
away the award for Entertainer of the
Year yeah so female hadn't won the award
since 2011 Taylor Swift now Miranda
Lambert who had been nominated before
but lost publicly campaign for Carrie to
win it in a night that celebrated women
it would have been a nice cap to it but
Garth Brooks Brooks won for the seventh
time and the CMA Award for Entertainer
of the Year
goes to
Garth Brooks
[Applause]
I've always tried to call it like I see
it if they gave this award for this show
tonight I'd have to give it to Reba
McEntire's performance for tonight ooh
that's good baby
Kelsea Ballerini if you want to know
what an entertainer is take a guitar and
just a single voice in the middle of an
arena and shrink a room fantastic
performance tonight really great
[Music]
[Applause]
cigar Brooks and to all of tonight's
winners thank you so much for being a
part of country music's biggest night
especially my amazing guest host dolly
and Reba put that show together knew
that there was a chance that Carrie
Underwood wasn't gonna win or
Entertainer of the Year don't give her
the script that thanks that congratulate
to the winner I know it's just really
that's thing there is a separation
obviously there's producers that put
together the broadcast show so they
wanted to make it about women and then
there's the voting academy so of course
there's no correlation between but we
all said the same thing in this room and
again country is one of those weird
genres where you don't have to be heavy
into hip-hop to know who the biggest
stars in hip-hop on but country is one
of those weird things that as an
outsider I'm not heavy into country to
me it seems the biggest stars in that
world are of course the women right and
when we were rehearsing for this show
right before we went on I read the part
that said Garth Brooks won Entertainer
of the Year there's five people in this
room that went Garth Brooks super for it
that's thing like he's not really
putting any new music so he didn't put
out any new music in the last sorry any
new albums in the last year he did put
up a couple singles like with Blake
Shelton but he hasn't released a new
album in the past year I know he's tours
like crazy yeah and that's what this
category really honors its Entertainer
of the Year because there's a male
vocalist and a female vocalist category
as well so this is about entertaining
but yeah I just it just seems a little
bit off that because she's been winning
winning this war for twenty eggs at 20
years so people want to Canada when it
would have been the great end to that
night if Carrie had won and you could
and I think that you you know the case
has to be made to those people who vote
because just like we were saying that
we're sort of on the outside of that
country world I think that they may be a
little bit too inside in that country
world because I think that if you are
actually going on Entertainer of the
Year somebody like Carrie Underwood is
massive in so many different genres and
in so many different parts of
entertainment where she's not just this
thing in a country world yeah like she
is so crossover it's not even funny and
you have to take that into account when
you're talking about the entertainment
power of an individual the fact that
she's able to entertain such a large
audience effortlessly and they all love
her music she doesn't have to change I
think that all that has to
be taken into account but it doesn't
look like they do but I kind of go back
to the same old same old
grief says he sells out here in Ireland
in ten minutes yeah missus he sells out
everywhere was in minutes I deserved
that he's amazing
he's a true talent Kenneth says
congratulations to him I love him and
his wife Trisha all the winners
congratulations to everyone that Garth
is still amazing almost seems likely
yeah this year just seemed like the
right time to give it to Carrie and just
yeah it didn't work out obviously I
think and I'm not saying give it to her
if she if she hasn't earned it right
celebrating women you got to give it to
the woman just cause I'm not saying that
but my god Carrie Underwood is aren't ya
Jay says Carrie is Wonder Woman no doubt
she has insane talent it means such an
impact this year but Garth is also a
classic country icon yeah